[Music]
I'm here with Ben Lackey from neo4j
director of cloud partner architecture
maybe you recognize him because we did a
video with him a few months back and now
they're here at Google Cloud next Ben
thank you so much for being here and for
talking to us can you tell us a little
bit about what neo4j is doing with
generative AI oh sure yeah uh we've been
really excited to be part of the launch
with uh Google and generative AI uh that
that work really kicked off in June and
at the time it focused on this kind of
two-part data flow uh so one part like
let's take some structured or
unstructured data feed it into
generative Ai and use generative AI to
create what are called Cipher statements
Cipher is a Neo for J's query language
and we can then run those statements
against the database to populate it so
what that architecture does is you're
going from data here that you may know
things about or nothing about at all and
you're extracting a graph from that
automatically previously that would have
been a whole bunch of work a lot of
manual ETL ESB all those wonderful
acronyms you're paying for it in compute
time you know fewer developer hours
you're burning a whole bunch of compute
but it's a much lower cost way to
automate this whole thing so that's like
part one of the data flow part two is
hey I've built this knowledge graph from
the unstructured or semi-structured data
uh how can I interact with it and what
we're seeing a lot of our customers do
is uh put a chatbot on top powered by
generative AI with Lang chain and that
converts natural language queries into
these Cipher queries that can be run
against the database you can get
information out and then present it back
to the user uh all sorts of nice things
about that working around the time cut
off for generative AI uh and helping
ground the results because presumably
what you've stored in your database is
factual versus whatever the Gen may come
up with which could potentially be a
hallucination that's very cool thank you
for sharing that okay so out of these
two parts yeah which is the most
interesting to you like which are you
most excited about I am biased on this
uh I spent way too long in the uh data
Plumbing space uh so like 20 years ago I
was working with large Banks to try to
move data around with straight through
processing systems and things like that
and it's fascinating to see how you can
automate large chunks of that process
now and you're seeing this all around us
uh Deutsche Bank has a booth over here
uh talking about using generative AI to
create client briefings and like I can
imagine all sorts of scenarios how these
architectures could work together for
use cases like that that's super
interesting I always love to hear with
your expertise what you're excited about
um can you tell me about anything new
that's coming up with NE 4J I can tell
you about a new thing that recently
happened which is a little different
than coming up but hopefully works I
believe it was August 17th very recently
uh we announced uh the ability to do
Vector search and index in the database
so right now people are very interested
in Vector databases to store these
vectors that can be uh fed into llms and
beddings of natural language and all
we're trying to do like a Best of Both
Worlds thing where we have that feature
but it can be attached to a graph and
the idea is it unlocks a use case around
semantic search so you take these free
form text documents uh once again you
use generative AI this time to compute
an embedding that embedding is stored in
the graph and is then searchable so you
can find other parts of the graph that
are similar similarities between
documents thank you so much for talking
to us as always it's a pleasure neo4j
our graph database partner here at
Google Cloud for a very long time uh and
I hope you have a great rest of the time
at the conference thanks so much all
right